in the lobby of Ramsey solutions talen
and terrier with us how are you guys
great good day merry Christmas to you
Merry Christmas yeah honor to have you
so where do you guys live
we're from Salt Lake City Utah fun
welcome to Nashville good to have you
and here to do your debt-free screen we
are and how much have you paid off about
a half a million dollars
oh holy exactly no just under half a
million that was three houses three
house mortgages okay all right so just a
little less than five hundred thousand
and that included three houses so I'm
guessing you sold some of them no no you
paid them down yeah we paid off our two
rentals and then we paid off our primary
mortgage how long did it take you to do
all that about four years good for you
that's amazing
making what kind of income during that
time well we started about 175,000 a
year and then quickly went to 245 and
now we're at 210 where'd it go you guys
that's amazing what do y'all do for a
living well for most of our lives we've
been social workers we in child welfare
workers and so one of the neat things
about your program is I mean it's
enabled us to financially do things you
wouldn't think that somebody with our
salaries could do so we did that and
then I'm in the National Guard and so
for part of that time I was active duty
with the National Guard and he and he
does side work as well he really does
three jobs I I didn't ever think I
thought only rich people could pay off
their houses will you make one hundred
seventy five thousand dollars a year I
don't know what you think rich people
are but we were social workers that
seemed like something that was just not
unreachable and so I mean I still do
social work but for me it definitely
gave me insight that you know he's
working extra jobs it has her social
workers and you're making a hundred and
seventy five thousand a year or two
hundred and ten thousand or two hundred
forty-five thousand yeah well so for
social workers better in Utah than they
do in Tennessee well if you stay in
something long enough and you're good at
it you get paid well and and that's the
key is you really have to you're not
working for the government no no we work
for charity and then I and then I do
I've been very successful for my side
work too as well and what is your side
for doing therapy doing therapy on the
side now and doing legal
legal work for attorneys okay now I'm
feeling better okay making more sense
good good so what happened four years
ago tell me your story about your
journey okay well it actually goes back
about 15 years ago my wife and I were
living and working in a group home
helping helping kids and I found a book
for 50 Cent's at the death at the at the
desert industries you know our thrift
shop called money answers I think was
your money answers book and so I didn't
understand your program at all but one
thing jumped out and that was this
snowball thing because I was like I've
already done that I'm as smart as this
Dave Ramsey guy and so because I figured
it out we were paying off our student
loan debt then I want to pay off the
smallest debt first cuz I wanted to
quick win and so so I read your stuff
but more like well it's at a cuter you
know I'm just as smart as Dave Ramsey so
it'll it'll be fine but what I found
over time was I read more and more stuff
less and less of Suze Orman and these
other guys because I didn't I didn't
agree with them and what I found over
I'll just tell you right now the more we
did the way you've outlined things in
your plan the more effective it's been
and every time I screwed up with money
I've looked back and you've been right
and I was wrong and so I just realized
it's just easier just to do it your way
thank you very much what the big crisis
for us happened I was deployed to Iraq
in 2005 and when I came back I wasn't I
wasn't engaged and I wasn't a good money
person anyway I was good at saving money
but it's like my youngest daughter her
favorite joke is to go dad is cheap and
then she makes the little sound and but
I came back from Iraq and and I was
working on my own stuff and my wife was
doing the best that she couldn't I
realized one day when we walked I walked
into the bank that we made six figures a
night I couldn't get fifty dollars out
of the bank we didn't have any money
they couldn't figure out where it went
and so that was kind of the first crisis
and that was when I I slowly with boa
constrictor like intensity began to rap
the Dave Ramsey program around my wife
which doesn't blow which doesn't which
doesn't work but I was like you know we
fought about money for years and so it
was it was just like standard and what
happened was later we did Financial
Peace University for our group home
staff because I realized I could spend a
hundred bucks in in a year your program
would save us way more than 100
we laid out plus it would provide them
with principles and it would it would
help them as people because they're
running the budgets inside our group
homes and Terry finally went to that and
I knew that I was getting through to her
when one day we were kind of talking
about arguing about money and she said
that's not what dave says to do what you
wish for yeah that was the first time
you you switch from being a curse word
to being on her side and so I had to
figure some things out so about four
years ago I was downsized and I was at
an agency where I was very successful
and it was very confusing it was a tough
time for me and my wife you know you
really take a hit to your to who you
think you are when you're not successful
and the great thing was I knew three
things from listening to you Dave one I
knew I need to get off my butt and
exercise two I knew that I somebody has
to make payroll I love that statement I
always thought having a job meant you
were successful and you had stability
and I realized if I'm as good as I think
I am I can I can have my own business
and a quitter was actually a great tool
for that and then later I also realized
you know we've got a pile of cash
there's one thing I've heard weren't an
emergency we got a pile up cash and you
know we weathered that storm and I took
it like a good politician I took the
crisis and I said honey we got to pay
off our houses we should be out of debt
and we really ratcheted down the budget
and the other thing that I learned from
you Dave was for us it wasn't handling
money that made the difference it was
the fact that I need to include my wife
as a partner in our money decisions even
if I didn't agree with the decisions
Harry how long have you all been married
20 20 good years of marriage Sharon said
the other day with 13 married 33 years
you said yeah we've got 25 good years of
marriage but the so Terry how different
are things when you get to speak into
them from your perspective oh it was a
lot more fair to me I always felt like
he was lying to me about the money so I
wouldn't spend it but I still made most
of major purchases so we were never on
the same page so now that we
kind of on the same page I'm I'm
constantly impressed when we're doing
our budget meeting I've got my budget
wallet here it's no high-class plastic
they develops but I was always impressed
when he would say no we need to put some
money aside for you to get clothes or
whatever because he knew it kept me
motivated to feel like it was there and
I could spend it but we knew where it
was going and it is a team that just
made a huge difference because we were
all on board I mean our teenage daughter
obviously struggled with it with the
idea but now she's very very good with
money
well she's watched YouTube do a complete
180 in that I testifies to a team when
you date guys do that and you really
last for years it sounds like I've been
pretty dramatic yeah there been a lot of
good changes I realize when we paid off
the houses in September we're in a
position where if we don't have jobs we
can still have immediate the same as
median income in the United States and
then if I go out and actually do a
little bit of work it gets even better
after that my first year and my that job
I was talking about that I was always
afraid to do but I didn't I didn't do
till I read quitter the military allowed
me to do a side job while I was doing on
military orders I made $30,000 my first
year and that was when I realized I do
have something to offer and I love
Daniel happens book thou shalt prosper
it makes a lot of good sense I found
that clients who were happy with me I
never have any trouble getting them to
pay me you know they want me to be happy
yeah and it's a way that they you know
demonstrate their respect so
congratulations how does it feel guys
amazing it is it is amazing our first
big project we're honored that we've
been a small part of you all making all
these decisions congratulations are very
proud of you thank you your honor honor
to know you and thank you for your
service to the country - all right it's
Thailand and Terry from Salt Lake City
Utah a half a million dollars paid off
that's they're rentals their houses
everything in four years making 175 up
to 245 back to 210 but it doesn't matter
now count it down let's hear a debt free
scream so this goes out to our son
Gareth who's deployed with Special
Forces operations in Afghanistan three
two one
I'm in love
awesome
oh man that's incredible well done you
guys very well done
this is the Dave Ramsey show you guys
would be so rich so fast and be able to
do so much not only for yourselves and
for your family but for others
Oh